okay let's check out this method to
literally copy-paste ads to make money
first off you don't want to run a
business where you have to actually like
buy products and like ship them out to
people okay so let's forget about
e-commerce or drop shipping or any of
that stuff doesn't work way too
expensive next you don't want to have to
fulfill the product you don't want to
have to do any work for it search for my
last name because the product we're
gonna be selling is actually my product
it's your kid on this get your
five-year-old on this making you money
and you can do it any age okay even if
you're three years old welcome back to
make guru today we have John crostini
now guys he is one of our most popular
fake gurus that we featured on this
channel
why does he's the man with the racks the
stacks got a comb-over so bad he wants
his hair back I'd like to introduce you
to my friend Benjamin and his friend
Benjamin and his friend Benjamin you
guys know you know you love him but what
you may not have realized is that John
crostini has been evolving
he's been evolving his channel now at
first you may have thought wow that that
seems like he's appealing to the lowest
common denominator when he's flashing
stacks of money like we saw on our last
video you'd be you'd be wrong just just
having a pile of money on your desk is
one thing but all crostini has taken the
wealth
clickbait to another level
[Music]
whoo gonna show you how to make $100 in
a day on whatsapp $100 every single day
using just sending emails with Twitter
using Instagram one hundred to a
thousand dollars in just minutes is what
you're gonna be learning you know I say
it all the time that gurus go after the
people who don't know a lot about money
they purposely target people who want to
be more successful they want to be more
wealthy which is why I use the money gun
to just kind of grab your attention but
he also wants to target people who don't
know what they're talking about and they
don't have any experience in personal
finance or wealth because those are the
easiest people you want to scam so that
is why John Chris Donnie has started
targeting children yes you heard me
right
John Chris Donnie you know he realized
that that that this age group that the
gurus haven't really targeted yet enough
is young impressionable kids you can do
this even if you have no experience you
can do this even if you have no tech
skills even if you don't even have a
computer or if you're not even 18 years
old even if you're not 18 years old so
no matter what age you are now what is
John Chris Donnie telling these kids to
do well to sell his product to tell his
fake guru system search for my last name
because the product we're gonna be
selling is actually my product so what
he does is he says hey he posts a bunch
of videos about how how to make a
hundred dollars a day on Twitter
Instagram what's up whatever it is and
then he tells you sell my product just
sell my product and he's not even subtle
about how little he trusts his little
army of toddlers to sell his sallies
product because he's pretty explicit
that he wants you to follow him
step-by-step don't change up what I'm
showing you here you try to be too
creative you try to be inventive it's
not going to work marketing is like a
key
to get every single piston right and
when you turn it the door will open you
get one thing wrong and the law the key
won't open the door and won't unlock
your income you need to unlock your
income with love with my little and what
is the key by the way what is the key
the key these are is these are your
secrets to get it's just a bunch it's
just to spam your friends now I get
these messages all day long that asked
me to sign up for different business
opportunity programs via text message
and this is the same sort of message
that you want to use for your message
that you're gonna send out via Twitter
listen to this here is the link you
asked about it's been a blessing for our
family this blessing is all yours enjoy
it and use for whatever dude you're
getting kids to do this even if you're
three years old get your kid on this get
your five-year-old on this making you
money people wonder why I make the fake
guru series guys we're out here trying
to save people from the NFL the no
friends left club we're trying to save
them this is how you get the no friends
left club you spam them with John
crostinis ads but John crostinis real
genius is targeting kids I gotta admit I
didn't see fake gurus going that far
John Kriss Donnie proves that he's going
willing to go to any lengths to get that
money gun filled up maybe any length so
guys that's all I wanted to notify you
of is what's going on with the crostini
how he's really innovated on the fake
guru method first it was look we're just
gonna promise wealth to you know people
who are over the age of 18 you know who
are adults now it's have we have we
tapped into the baby market enough have
we tapped into the toddler market enough
welcome to baby core
even if you're three years old get your
kid on this get your five-year-old on
this making you money
[Music]
[Music]
but never to the trust
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]